welcome back to the iced coffee hour I'm
Ellie Choi and so far this podcast has
made
230 thousand dollars very close that was
a fantastic it's 247
000. oh that was good you're one of the
closest we've ever had I think that's
okay so I I kind of like watched one
from like a month ago so yeah that was
that was a good guess thank you welcome
to Vegas thank you what are you doing
here I'm here for trade show actually a
clothing a clothing trade show it's
called Magic sourcing so here to like
talk to manufacturers so I was here for
like the past few days doing that is
that manufacturers for like a personal
brand or something like that for
clothing for clothing yeah so just
trying to find new manufacturers and
factors and this is your merch line yeah
for copyright so we've seen your videos
from back in the day I remember when it
was a big thing to do like a day in the
life of a Harvard student uh life of
Yale students and then there's you day
in the life of Vanderbilt yeah and that
video got how many was it five million
views four million no not that much yeah
around two I think
yeah yeah and that was your was that
your first video ever so that's my first
public video but maybe overall like my
seventh video seventh video yeah was
that like the first video you took
seriously or was it like yeah that was
like okay so I made a few videos about
like flipping and reselling because I
used to do that in high school very
scary V inspired and then I made some
videos about like selling on Amazon
because I used to do that and that was
terrible and that took a year off and
then my first real attempt back was that
day in the life video and it just
absolutely popped off it did really well
for like my first real attempt at
YouTube and honestly I think like having
the other videos beforehand kind of
helped with that though it's pretty
amazing because like you gained 50 000
subscribers in just like two months
right
I think I have a video named something
like that yeah what was so special about
that Vanderbilt video why do you think
so many people watched it yeah there was
like a ton of being the life videos at
the time like Harvard like you said
Harvard Princeton like any other college
there's like a ton of viral videos and
then with my school Vanderbilt there was
only like one video A Day in the Life
video and I had 10K views so I was like
okay like if I make a decent video it'll
probably do well and I got lucky and it
ended up doing well so I spent like a
week like researching because at the
time this is 2018 at the time the only
thing you needed was good watch time and
good a good click-through rate and then
it's like a viral video nowadays it's a
little different tell us about that
video what did you do in that video in
that video specifically that made it
yeah to perform well yeah like how was
your day oh how was my day
um is it really like regular video just
like wake up breakfast I read a book
maybe like went to classes went to the
gym hung out with friends very normal
average day
um I think what made it like do well was
a lot of the other videos uh Day in the
Life videos there's a lot of people kind
of talking and not showing and I was
like kind of bothered by that I was like
oh I want to know like how long are your
classes or like how nice are the
amenities there like at your college
campus
um so I try to like lean into that and
fix some of those things that I saw and
those problems Day in the Life videos I
have a feeling that someone picks like
if you're gonna make one of those Day in
the Life videos you're gonna pick out a
day that you have a lot of exciting
things going on yeah did you do that or
did you just do like it so you you
picked out a daily like okay I'm gonna
read it's my first time reading in two
months
yeah exactly I'm gonna do like a cold
shower in journal but yeah some of it is
definitely like hyped up a little bit
Yeah I think that's also just like my
effort to like really show like a
variety of things that maybe I wouldn't
just go into one day but like an average
of of multiple different days so I was
really thinking about like myself as
like a high school student looking up in
the life videos for my school and not
finding anything that was like actually
relevant or actually that information
National so do you think that goes into
a high schooler's decision oh yeah do
they YouTube like day in the life of uh
you know when I was making College
videos like guaranteed a ton of those
viewers were high schoolers really yeah
just and even myself like when I got
accepted into Vandy I was like looking
up in the life videos and there was none
that was like super super good or well
produced or anything so even myself I
was like looking at stuff like that how
did you pick Vanderbilt Vanderbilt they
gave me good financial aid okay so they
threw me a lot of money and I said okay
I'll go did you apply to like Harvard
Yale no no not really
um I only applied to mostly State
schools okay like maybe like USC Cornell
Vanderbilt like those are the ones you
know probably yeah yeah so yeah and that
video did extremely well did it do well
out the gate or did it take a while to
like start catching on I have some like
screenshots I don't remember exactly
um maybe like I want to say like 10K
views in the first week which is crazy
for me yeah coming from 100 views Max on
some of those older videos so 10K views
off the gate and then within the span of
a few months like and that probably 20
30 40 up to maybe a hundred wow do you
get at a college campus after that I'm
sorry I'm so curious because everyone
must be like yo that's Ellie that he had
that video that's funny no I feel like
my peers like didn't didn't know at all
like anyone in my grade it was more so
like I really noticed it when a new
Freshman Class came in because every
single one of those freshmen coming into
the school like had watched that video
because they're just like just like me
when I was a senior in high school just
curious about like what is college life
like and like what am I gonna expect
like what do I what am I gonna
experience they're just like so curious
so that was weird and then the next
freshman class after that it was even
more so that's the first week of like a
new semester was always pretty
interesting really yeah but definitely
not like my people in my grade what did
you go to study there I studied business
yeah just like
General business so it was your
expectation you were gonna graduate and
then just go in the field of yeah like
what did you want to be sure I wanted to
go into IB like Investment Banking uh
sophomore I wanted to be like in
Consulting and I'm like so glad either
like I'm so glad I skipped that but I
was very much just like um
I was kind of brainwashed it's really
like oh that's like what I'm supposed to
do that's like the best job you can get
it's like IV or Consulting so how many
of your friends went into Investment
Banking a good amount actually right
around like my year Investment Banking
is becoming less popular and Consulting
was becoming more popular mostly
probably because of like the work
culture and that type of thing so a lot
of people a lot of my friends are in
Consulting and then a good amount are
also in like Tech like from college
specifically it sounds stupid what does
a consultant do because I I would have a
hard time imagining like what a fresh
college graduate no yeah could consult
on for like a large company you would
think that they would just hire people
with prior experience in the industry to
consult right right yeah I don't I I
mean I never worked a consulting job so
I couldn't tell you
um I guess my friends would say they
just like apply problem solving like
Frameworks I guess I don't I don't know
I was never a consultant so I don't know
exact same way yeah I never knew what it
was because I was studying econ at UCSB
okay I was like I was like okay like I
go into Consulting
what is that like I have no idea
Consulting is one of those buzzwords now
it's like democratizing whatever it is
you know I mean like it means a lot of
other things that are under control
people throw that in to confuse you yeah
like I do Consulting all right it's one
of those things that just like I do real
estate yeah okay but it could mean
anything yeah it really could that's
interesting so but at what point then
did you realize it's like I'm not gonna
do Consulting I'm not going to do
investment banking the YouTube channel
is popping off I'm gonna be a YouTuber
it was like a very gradual process for
me I definitely started off like
not really convinced that YouTube was
going to work out like I was still like
trying to get summer internships and
that type of thing and then I remember
like there being a little bit of a
turning point which was I made like this
viral video and it ended up like making
a lot of Revenue like off that it's from
AdSense and then that that was like
really a turning point because I had I
hadn't really made money from YouTube
before that and then at that point I was
like oh like you can actually like make
money from YouTube like you know
comparable to what I might make it like
a consulting job or a finance job so for
me was like okay like I always like
do YouTube on the side right like that's
what I was doing at the time full-time
student YouTube on the side maybe I was
like oh maybe I'll just like go work a
normal job do YouTube on the side but
yeah definitely had a point kind of like
which what was that video that was
giving Harvard students an iPhone
um if you saw that video Yeah giving
away iPhone at Harvard or something yeah
that was like a very different video but
I was in a group chat with like with
like Jimmy and Mr Beast like uh Ryan a
few other friends and like it was called
I forget what it's called 10 Milli
bangers or something and we were just
focused on making a video with 10
million views and so I was very
influenced by them and I was like oh I
need to make a viral video I need to
make a viral video so uh that was my
effort at that and yeah I think it got
like 24 million views or something wait
wait what goes on in this this Secret
Squirrel
it's totally dead now yeah it's totally
dead I feel like they just like start up
and then like they kind of die but what
was going on in there like how did you
get access to that I was friends with
Ryan so Ryan Trahan yeah great YouTuber
um
yeah I met Ryan like at a talk that I
gave with him and my other friend
um friends conference and yeah that was
how I met Ryan and then Ryan kind of
invited me in but what goes on in there
like just conversations about like oh
this video is it gonna do well like why
is it gonna do well
um a lot of like thumbnail comparisons
like what's the what's a better
thumbnail and why
um
a lot of times like previewing each
other's videos and like we used to do
like a weekly call where we just like
gave feedback and like kind of roasted
each other how long ago was that this
was a while ago this was like my
sophomore junior year of college was it
intimidating to be in that group
um not intimidating
um it was just like super exciting just
because yeah it was just fun to like
learn yeah and jam but first we gotta
thank our sponsor ftxus as you probably
have noticed cryptocurrency prices are
down quite a bit from their Peak and now
could be a time to buy in well below
where prices were just about six months
ago and FTX us wants to help they're
used by millions of users including us
to buy sell track and trade both crypto
and nfts all in one place with fees that
are up to 85 lower than the top
competitors and that's exactly why we
recommend you guys check out FTX with
that link down below yeah and Jack I'll
show you exactly how easy it is all you
have to do is go and select what you
want to buy how much of it you want to
buy how often you want to buy it and
then you swipe right and you're done and
by the way every trade you make over ten
dollars gives you free crypto they
actually just launched FTX stocks so now
it's an app where you can trade crypto
and nfts and stocks all in one place
it's gonna be absolutely amazing
definitely check it out with that link
down below and they also recently spent
250 million dollars expanding their
Equity trading infrastructure to ensure
that even their stock trades don't have
fees again the link is down below in the
description enjoy thank you guys so much
and now with that said let's get back to
the podcast Chris idea was it to go to
Harvard and give away iPhones whose idea
was it was it yours yeah okay yeah I um
so at the time like when I made this
video there were a ton of really viral
videos where people were giving away
iPhones and I had done like a Harvard
Day in the Life video and that had done
like super well like a few million views
so I was like okay like trivia giving
away iPhones already hitting 10 millions
of views or whatever and then like my
day in the life video at Harvard already
had like a few million views and I was
like let me just combine the two and
like do that so it's kind of like on
brand and like I don't know
did you know it was going to be a banger
yeah when I was planning it I was like
oh this is gonna go viral like this is
gonna be this is gonna be big oh sorry
go for it yeah no I thought it was going
to reach like a few a few million views
but um it did like way better than that
so how much did that video make you okay
so this is a really interesting story
um
I basically had three thousand dollars
in my bank account when I made that
video uh I spent two thousand dollars on
the two iPhones that I gave away five
hundred dollars on a round-trip flight
to Boston from Vanderbilt and so I had
like 500 in my bank account when I went
to Boston and I was like I was really
like I put all my chips on on one thing
I was just like okay this is gonna this
has to do well or else I'm like I'm
screwed
um the video made like I think like
right now it's close to a hundred okay
so maybe around like 98 99 in that ring
I don't know I don't know the last time
I checked hopefully it's an incredible
Roi yeah it was like
I can't tell you I was like how insane
that feeling was because I remember I
had like 500 left my bank account
and the first week I think in the first
six days it had six million views or
something like that holy cow and then
the AdSense hit like the first check for
AdSense was like 20 or 30 or 40.
something like that and so imagine going
from like 500 never having more than
four thousand five thousand dollars in
my bank account ever to now having like
my first check of that 100K was 20 30
40K and so like I literally felt I I can
imagine like what it feels like to win
the lottery yeah because it literally
felt like that it was like the most
insane hive ever felt in my life yeah
and like even just talking about it
right now I'm like kind of like bringing
myself back and like oh my God like
sophomore year junior year Elliott was
just like I was just off the walls so
how do you not then just go back to
Harvard and do it again yeah why not
just repeat you found a winning thing
just keep doing that yeah I didn't like
want to end up being one of those
creators that like just did interviews
and stuff
um I get that question a lot like why
didn't I just go back and do it but at
the end of the day like I love making
Vlogs like I like making videos about my
life and you know like that type of
video is more of like a hosting role
than like a main character role if you
want to make that comparison so for me
it's like I really cared about like
sharing stories about my life and
sharing my perspective and although like
that type of video does well and makes a
lot of money like makes you successful
because you get a get a lot of
subscribers I got like 400k subscribers
for that video
um yeah it just like wasn't what I
wanted so I went back to like just
making normal like Vlogs yeah what's
amazing to me is that you gained 400 000
subscribers from that video but still
You Were Somehow able to Pivot to
vlogging where usually like you see
someone grow and then they pivot and
then their child their Channel dies yeah
but you also have amazing engagement for
the amount of subscribers that you have
you have like 1.2 million subscribers
but each of your videos gets like 200k
views which is like nearly 20 engagement
which is fantastic so how were you able
to Pivot in such a successful way do you
think yeah actually it's funny because
like I went from having a few million
views on that video and then the next
video I posted it like just went back to
my normal viewership I thought my life
was like totally changed after I hit
that viral video I was like oh my God
all My Views are going to deal super
well now so I experienced like a lot of
burnout after because I was like okay
that's not the case I think how it ends
up working out is usually like that's
the top of the funnel like people might
find your channel that way and they
might subscribe for that type of content
and then the videos I was making like
not really the type of content that
people subscribe for but there's still
some a little bit of overlap people
interested in college or people
interested in like college life in
general so yeah I think that kind of
helped but um I was trying to find this
like I'm sure you guys do this too but
like find this fine balance between
making videos that bring new people in
and then making videos that also kind of
like
keep people in the ecosystem and keep
people engaged now is that the time you
decided to go full time I I really
didn't decide to do full-time YouTube
until like my second semester senior
year of college like three years in and
still was like ah should I go like apply
for a job
um I come from like a pretty like
conservative family and so they were
definitely like pushing for me to just
like go get a job so it took a lot of
like I don't know even though it was
like a no-brainer for most people like I
feel like it would be a no-brainer for
me it was still a very like last minute
decision of like okay I'm just like I'm
gonna do YouTube like after I graduate
college so yeah how much were you making
at the time where you decided all right
I'm doing this I decided to do YouTube
full-time like that that full-time
decision was when I was making as much
as I would at like a consulting job and
so I was like if I'm gonna make the same
amount but I can do what I loved
then there's no there's no opportunity
cost in like going to go work a
corporate job because it's not like I'd
be making more money there it's not like
I'd be having more fun it's not like at
the time it wasn't like I was getting
more opportunities so for me it's just
like okay when the pendulum kind of like
switched over to okay most of the
opportunity is on on the YouTube side
that's when it made sense for me to like
really commit to that it was like 100
100 Grand a month or a year or something
yeah 100 a month I was like
a consult person yeah
yeah
not like that I just misspoke yeah when
people say like uh when sometimes we'll
ask like how much you mean it'll be like
80 grand I'm like I always think a month
everything a month oh 80 grand theft
that's not bad at all that's that's okay
yeah
we can work on it um no that was that
was huge for me like the six figure
threshold yeah um
definitely like okay I can I can do this
like full time yeah what did your
parents think about it
um at first they were like very very
hesitant very reluctant they definitely
were like every time I went back home
for break they're like so were you
working next year were you getting that
internship
um but over time they I'm kind of like
I'm very stubborn and especially with my
parents I'm very stubborn
um they know now like
if I if I'm gonna do something I'm just
gonna do it like they can't really
change my mind so over time they just
gave up and yeah
they're very supportive now like of
course what do you Vlog now if someone
asks like what your style is or why
people watch yeah what would you say
um you mentioned like Day in the Life
videos it's kind of like dangerous just
like honestly like a bunch of daily life
videos but they're just Vlogs and now I
live in New York instead of on a college
campus and so a lot of it is just like
me hanging out with my friends getting
coffee and that just sounds like my life
to me that sounds like the life you go
out you hang out with your friends you
just film it right like everyone already
does like on Snapchat and stuff like
that yeah you post it you make a bunch
of money
how is that are you just like on cloud
nine I mean lifestyle content is great
in that like yeah you can just live your
life and then document it and that's
like very natural and organic I would
say like it has its own consequences and
like its own I don't know there's
there's sacrifices that you make because
your work and your life are so
intertwined
and sometimes I wish that I could just
like have work mode which is like going
in and like making a video producing a
video and then like getting off and then
like just kind of being on personal time
if that makes sense so yeah it's hard
because like if you so in college like I
was making videos about being in college
and so once I graduated college like I
had to make videos about being someone
who makes videos and so it's a very like
weird Loop where you're like okay if
most of my day is consumed by like
thinking about how to make videos like
what are you actually making videos
about so that's like a very like
challenging thing as a lifestyle Creator
is like okay then you have to go make
your life interesting you have to go
like do things that are interesting
otherwise it's not going to be
entertaining to watch so
yeah you hear that from a lot of
vloggers but what about like the David
dobrik kind of Vlogs yeah I think that
you can produce something similar to
that
I don't think so you don't think you
want to yeah I definitely would not it's
just like to produce for me and like
yeah it's crazy I just realized that
style has officially died out
there David's not posting no but Logan
Paul was doing that remember that yeah
Logan before David though didn't he I
think so but there was that that brief
period of time where everybody I feel
like did the David dobrik route is like
five minute videos just clip with high
retention yeah I have not seen a video
like that and then but then now I feel
like we went the Emma Chamberlain route
of just like these long 20 minute Vlogs
very low editing just very personal I
don't think we're there yet I think
we're not at no I don't think we're at
the Emma Chamberlain like Emma pulls it
off really well yeah but I think like it
is a it is a bit of a pendulum
I don't know there's still I feel like
the dominant thing is still like fast
paced it's not as like it's not like
David dobrik's style but it's still I
agree it's fast paced and also like
challenges like that's kind of what's
like popping off yeah but you also can't
compare like
10 million views on a challenge video
sure to like and then my Chamberlain
video it's like totally different yeah
but first we want to think today's
sponsor short form reading is really one
of the best ways to understand complex
and confusing Financial topics but one
of the really difficult Parts is just
finding the time especially when books
are like 500 pages long thankfully
though it's nice to get some of that
time back with short form short form is
an amazing book guide that not only
gives you comprehensive book summaries
but also expert analysis with very
useful Comprehension exercises short
form also offers a ton of different book
genres to choose from and my personal
favorites are business finance and
Entrepreneurship I recently used short
form on a book called to sell is human
and it was able to break down the very
complicated subject of contemporary
selling in just a couple sentences so
instead of spending days on a 272 page
book I was able to get all of the key
ideas in less than 10 minutes my
favorite part of short form is that
you're able to choose the length of your
summary I could choose to read the
chapter by chapter guide or just a
single page summary short form publishes
new book guides and articles every week
and short forms drivers get to vote on
which book comes next so to get five
days of unlimited access plus a 20
discount on an annual subscription you
can visit the link Down Below in the
description or go to shortform.com copy
to get started today again the link is
down below in the description get
started and save tons of time today and
with that said back to the podcast how
are you able to cultivate such a
dedicated audience I still can't wrap my
head around it because like like I said
you have like what 200 000 followers on
Instagram but you have videos or photos
that get like 50 000 likes those ratios
are insane like the people that follow
you they actually watch all of your
content it's not like they just like hit
subscribe and they don't stick around
how are you able to keep these people
around is it just because you're very
personal in your videos I think it it is
that like when you spend 10 minutes a
week with someone and like you share
kind of like what's going on in your
mind a lot of times I think the the
relationship that I like compared to is
like if I was like FaceTiming my friend
like and I'm updating them on like what
my week looks like or like like what I'm
up to and just like having almost like
if you're hanging out like the way we're
hanging out but then imagine there's
like I mean it's kind of like this
actually where you have like another
person just kind of sitting in on on
that conversation and you can directly
address that person if you want
sometimes and that's pretty much like
they're a part of this friend group and
they're just like hanging out with you
so in that way I think a lot of times
people come up to me and they're like
hey like it's me like you know me right
like but I have no idea who they are but
I get it because like I I sometimes
watch creators and I've also like been
like had that feeling of like oh it's me
like we're friends like you know yeah
exactly yeah so I think like that
creates a very strong bond because in a
way like they don't feel like just a fan
but they just feel like a friend so
I think that's like a huge I don't know
for me it's like a great part about
making like personal videos is that you
get to develop like a personal
relationship with your viewer and would
you say you're very genuine in your
YouTube videos and can viewers sense
people being genuine or not of course
he's gonna say yes he's genuine I'm
actually fake
actually everything I just wondering
actually everything is just fake you
know viewers can tell a Creator is being
genuine or not yeah 100 like it's
uncanny how viewers know like
certain things like we like I never talk
about sometimes they just know like so
you can sense like the craziest things
like that they would have no idea what's
going on but like sometimes they'll DM
me and they're like hey Elliot you okay
like you look a little down today I was
like or like they're like is there
something going on between like you and
a friend like you know they're just I'm
just like how could you know that like
it makes no sense but there's some smart
there's some smart people out there
highly like emotionally intelligent just
it's crazy people tell me all the time
you look tired
no half the time it's the lighting bad
lighting makes sense are you tired
sometimes yeah somebody's I'm not tired
and being like oh man you look tired I'm
like it's the lighting that's why that's
why Graham's so particular about the
lighting yeah it's like the tired of the
comments tired to counteract the lack of
sleep that's funny how is your business
broken down now like YouTube in general
um
I mean a lot of it is so for a long time
you use copyrighted music for a while so
AdSense is like I still mostly use like
nowadays I do use non-copyrighted but
it's I've never like relied on AdSense
um it's just like not as high for
lifestyle creators and so mostly like
brand deals for sure
um and then a huge part is like the
clothing copyright
um sorry that's confusing because I just
talked about copyright but um no the
clothing is called copyright and then
yeah so
clothing brand deals AdSense it's kind
of like the mix for YouTube
um and then of course it's like random
things on the side but yeah can you give
us a rough like you know estimate on
what your income would be every month it
fluctuates okay a lot
um because some months I'll do a drop
some once I don't do drop so that makes
a huge difference because I only like do
drop every few months
um it really varies like yeah I will say
like I have seen it like for some reason
I always imagine that like my my channel
is dying and like my career is gonna die
man every single day I'm like oh my God
this is it yeah like we just hit the
Apex and like we're going downhill now
um but you know you had Shelby on here a
few months or maybe a month ago or
whatever we were talking because we had
like a we went on like a trip together
and she was like yeah like you know like
my income just keeps growing and I'm
like okay like you know she's a little
bit more it has a few more years on me
I'm like okay like I'm just gonna keep
it up because like hopefully it'll just
like keep growing it really is like
interesting how more opportunities just
like keep coming up and sometimes that's
like a problem because you don't really
know which ones to choose uh just
because you have so many but it's a
great problem to have but it gets
distracting sometimes for sure so it's
extremely variable basically it is it is
um yeah I feel like I don't know if you
guys feel about it but mine's extremely
very in general like really we'll go
like 2X and then like 50 yeah because
you could have a great like brand deal
or you could have like a good month in
views
um you can you can control it a little
bit but sometimes you I mean I don't
know sometimes you can't so do you ever
worry that making more money is gonna
make you seem less relatable that all of
a sudden you're like a rich guy who's
like oh he's pretending to be you know
really the wrong way yeah yeah if you
get you know too flashy then it's like
oh he doesn't get it anymore yeah it's
definitely like a risk like you've I've
seen it happen to like a lot of people
where they become very successful and
then they're like suddenly out of touch
um it's a thing like especially for
lifestyle creators I think for me like
my goal is just to like be genuine be
authentic like if I am like making more
like I'm not I'm not gonna hide it like
I'm not gonna like go uh some people
like I don't know I'm not calling anyone
out but um you might like go like live
in like a small apartment because you're
like oh like
um you know I don't make any money or
sometimes people will just be like oh I
don't make money like I'm broke they're
clearly not broke um I'm never gonna be
like Oh I'm broke like when I'm not
broke but
um I think that's that's important like
that trust in like a viewer like as long
as you're being honest it's like fine I
think like I know I I follow some
creators that like I know make a lot of
money and like it's not like I like them
any less because they make more like I'm
happy for them like I root like I think
true fans they like root for your
success
um so I've never been like oh I need to
like hide like if I'm making money of
course there's a risk of like you don't
want to like this is just me as a person
like I don't want to be overly flashy
like I don't want to like Flex on anyone
like that's not the goal so yeah I think
just being like being yourself with it
like and if you're just like person
about it then it'll probably just bite
you in the butt I agree I think it
depends on how you use it right like if
you're making a bunch of money and
you're like guys I'm like I can't
believe it this is amazing like I'm so
fortunate to be in the position I'm in
uh then people are rooting for you yeah
but if you're if you're just like oh
yeah I just got this new car I got this
ice you know what I mean yeah there's a
way to do it yeah yeah Danny Duncan was
a great example of that I remember when
I first met Danny he was living I think
it was a one bedroom apartment in
Hollywood I knew he was making a killing
guy didn't spend money and that was just
him I mean but he invested so well too
oh really yeah that's awesome he's so
he's so smart behind the scenes but yeah
he's just a one bedroom apartment
Hollywood he just went there every now
and then yeah uh I think it's like trash
I've seen some of the videos he's just
throwing people against the wall I feel
bad for the landlord yeah but yeah I
mean I I goes to show you I mean it was
he was really authentic with a lot of
like he's spending in his his videos I
think I was like just chatting with him
like I think he's like a very just
Downer like he's a real guy you know
like yeah it doesn't try to like just
like shows it as it is and I think
that's the best way to do it
eventually if you just are faking it
it'll eventually like bite you in the
buds yeah now you were mentioning that
your phone is black and white is there a
reason for that like you've said you
never saw the colors of the podcast room
yeah yeah it's all maybe I've seen it
but like maybe it's just because I
walked in and it was like in person
um yeah my phone is in black and white
it's just uh
that's just the way is it healthy is it
better or like working like that what is
it what does that do is there I bet
there's a study there's got to be a
Vanderbilt study done this right so
black and white is better on the eyes
smarter or something like that yeah I
don't I don't know the study and I don't
know where I started like when I started
doing this in college I think and I
don't know if I read it somewhere
probably like I've had it for a little
bit yeah I mean sometimes like I go
through faces where it's color but like
I'm in a good phase right now where it's
been black and white for a while good
phase yeah this one's a good one what
does it do it just like keeps me off my
phone if you um I have this I'm I'm just
like very addicted to my phone because
well everyone is and then also like we
do it for our job so it's also there's
that factor
um I just when I'm scrolling through
Instagram stories like it doesn't it's
just not yeah it's just not as like fun
to look at so then you end up putting it
down versus if you um are scrolling with
color it's just like I don't know you
could scroll for hours yeah what about
for things like if you're studying
someone else's YouTube thumbnail you
know you you want to look at their
colors or you're taking photos how does
that work out yeah it's funny like I
take all my photos in black and white
and then like sometimes I'll like send
them over to like my friend and it's
terrible like the lighting is so bad
that would be a great way to test
thumbnails though is do it black and
white and see if if you could get it to
stand out in terms of just the visuals
alone and then you could act as
interesting yeah
because that will also show you contrast
pretty well honestly like not not that
well like sometimes I'm like this is a
great photo and then it's just like
terrible it's terrible yeah but that
makes sense I don't know it's a small
price to pay to stay off my phone I get
very like jittery if I like spend too
much time on my phone
um I don't have tick tock on my phone I
just like I don't know
Tick Tock is way too addicting I feel
like every episode I I talk to you love
to talk about tick tock tick tock yeah
it's bad it's bad yeah it's gotten to
the point I I've been trash talking it
for such a long time but now uh anytime
I have like just down time where I know
I just want to like my mind is gonna go
to Mush for five minutes I'm like all
right open Tick Tock and just see what's
up there and uh yeah 20 minutes goes by
so so bad yeah 20 minutes not bad no 20
minutes is not bad that means you have a
lot of self you know what actually we
could look at the I turned on the um the
screen time oh nice oh yeah okay so a
long time ago we had someone on the on
the podcast we were talking about screen
time and I was so curious what grams was
because he's like working all the time
yeah yeah let's recompare this should we
guess can I guess yes or in a half hours
too much WoW four hours and 42 minutes
oh yeah but okay now let's see YouTube
yeah oh god oh this isn't terrible I
don't think yeah that's not per day okay
no so this is uh what is this in the
last week I've spent seven hours and 30
minutes on YouTube two hours 14 minutes
on maps but that doesn't really count
because that like if we get rid of masks
two hours on iMessage but sometimes I
just leave it open like all two hours oh
okay respond to a text but then I'll
leave my phone like that what what I
don't know because sometimes someone's
typing and I just don't want to click
out of it oh it's a little bubble uh on
Instagram wow that's actually higher
than I expected an hour on Tick Tock in
four days so what is that uh a little
under 20 minutes a day six hours and
nine minutes yeah and I have three hours
on YouTube two hours three hours on
Safari two and a half hours on Instagram
two hours on Google Maps yeah an hour
and a half on Tick Tock it's bad I'm
running around like four hours like
under four daily average try that black
and white thing which is still not great
but I was it was a lot worse yeah like
six to eight hours at one point now
switching topics here you were saying
that you watched Jack's video oh yeah
you saw okay well it came up like on my
way here on your way here yeah yeah I
didn't see it I haven't clicked on it
yeah let me say first off shout out to
Sean rizwan okay yeah I know Sean yeah I
know that yeah you guys hang out yeah
yeah yeah well he gave me that thumbnail
suggestion and it was a banger thumbnail
and I liked it a lot yeah but yeah like
the the asking Strangers Like Money
questions yeah that stuff's just like
popping off right now yeah I thought to
myself I think I could do this okay yeah
so I went out to like downtown Vegas
nice and went but for some reason it's
like blowing up on Tick Tock there you
go on Tick Tock I eat it up it's good
it's a good format yeah my I mean my
most viral video is me asking questions
to strangers I like the idea of being
able to get content just kind of like
letting strangers be strange yeah you
know what I mean yeah just going up to
them and letting like you know what I
mean like getting some weird
conversation seeing where they take it
it's not a new thing either you guys
know like humans of New York like it's
like a vlog yeah and it used to be very
very popular I don't know if it's as
popular anymore but it's a similar
concept like going out and like
interviewing just random strangers in
New York and it was like it was huge and
like this is like the Next Generation
I've always like there have always been
pranks like that's always been huge on
YouTube yeah of course like telling
jokes to people stuff like that it's
always been huge but it's just showing
up right now finally for like Finance
like people are like talking about their
income and stuff you could one-up this
by going to Fremont Street at night on a
weekend
you need to do this
great idea yeah I feel like you Jack
Manly but money yes because you know
what you went you went in the middle of
it
you went in the middle of the day yeah
that place gets crazy at night and just
imagine the interactions you're having
it would be ten times what you did 30 of
the people I interacted with during the
day were already drunk imagine nights
imagine how about this you pay people
five dollars to tell you their net worth
oh they would just tell me anyways man
really yeah there was something they'll
just tell you yeah I just went out to
people they were all cool like some
people rejected me but overall I would
say like 80 75 of people were okay with
it if they're wasted though like I don't
know you can if you can like really
assess The credibility of the oh that's
like yeah if you're just like really
drunk and someone's like what's your net
worth I don't know how honest that is
I'll do that at night yeah I would try
it at night maybe the net worth question
people are gonna be like what's a net
worth yeah that would be good that's
good content you know but a really
simple like a finance question really
easy I love those videos where people go
up and like all right how many
continents are there and people say oh
continent yeah what's the content guys
like favorite videos I want to do
something like that I have a great idea
I love the videos where uh the the news
reporter whoever make up a fact so you
should just make up a crazy fact like so
did you hear that the president just
raised the interest rates by 20 and just
see what people say that's good too
somebody oh oh I expected it from that
guy yeah yeah that's good yeah did you
oh you say did you hear about this and
then they say oh yeah I heard about it
completely false there's like a
statistic it's like um or like not
there's a study maybe some Vanderbilt
study I don't know they're like oh just
say any thing if you say a fact it's it
doesn't have to be true but not a fact I
guess if you say any general statement
about anything but you add like a little
bit of specificity to it people will
worry 90 of times say like it's okay
yeah I believe that that's that's real
yeah so you could probably pull that off
it'd be a good piece of code yeah you
know what man what go to Fremont at
night on a weekend ask people what their
thoughts are on Andrew Tate
you would get some wild answers that's a
good idea Wild Adventures done I get
credit for that tomorrow see you tonight
you run into me and I'm like I'm just
like
oh no I have to go to three months yeah
yeah but but get like everyone from like
old young man yeah yeah okay
professional like just I just gotta go
and like collect footage for like five
hours yeah just go and just get as much
as I can but realistically that's what
you should be doing is spending like you
know eight hours yeah from honestly from
6 p.m to probably 2 A.M if you can yeah
and get a wide range of questions spend
three hours Andrew take three hours net
worth three hours something that's what
I did yeah when I shot the first time I
probably shot for nearly five hours and
it was like midday was burning hot it
was really hot it's a lot yeah and I
mean the end product was like a nine
minute video yeah so but why does it
take so long was that because a lot of
people said no or they their answers
weren't interesting uh a lot of people
said I was extremely anxious to be
honest it was very hard for me to go up
to people people and like ask them
personal questions in general just like
for me going up to someone's very
challenging so a lot of the times if you
look at the raw footage just like I
can't do this JJ I can't do it and JJ's
like you got it man just one more we
need one more I'm like okay I think I
got it and then I walk up to someone I
like immediately turn around nope I
can't do it I can't do it JJ but that
was a lot of the raw footage to be
honest but it was very draining yeah but
that's why it took so long so at the end
the security guard came up and gave you
guys a bit of a hard time oh really what
happened yeah okay so I got in trouble I
was like approaching these this couple
and the security guard came up to me on
a bike and he's saying oh you can't do
that you can't do that and I cut the
video and then I went back in and I was
just finishing the interview with the
people so the guy came up to me he's
like okay these Brands behind us if
you're making money off of this they
don't want their like logos shown it was
like White Castle and like audio Brands
and I was like oh no I'm not making
money off that channel wasn't monetized
when I said that so it wasn't
technically lying sure now it's
monetized made like 40 bucks okay so if
these guys
okay yeah they can have my forty dollars
that I I don't believe it either as a
public space yeah but you know I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna like argue with a
cop guy you know I don't know I think
you'll be fine yeah I think so too I
don't think White Castle is going to
come after you yeah but it was funny
because he comes up and he's like you
can't do this and he's like all mad he's
like don't put the camera and he slaps
my hand away yeah then it cuts and I'm
just asking the same people the question
he's just gone you know what it would
have been funny to get him to answer if
he went to college
yeah
he was not in any good mood though he
was very upset that's funny like you
just got to push the boundaries like
never stop recording and you just you
just kind of go with it I think I could
yeah I think I could do that but I had
like during hour four and five I was
getting much more comfortable yeah so
I'd probably have to be near the talent
but yeah I would I would love to do so
it's hard going up to people and just
like it's some practice it's really hard
yeah I once tried to film this video
where I was uh selling like trying to go
from like a dollar to like 100 or a
thousand dollars in a weekend or a week
and I just filmed the first day and for
some reason I was filming 4K which is
terrible
um and I just like six hours of me
trying to sell water bottles of people
and I scrapped the video because it was
so bad it was so hard but um a lot of it
was same exact thing me just being like
[ __ ] I cannot do this like yeah I do not
want to go up to people and like ask
them to buy this one one is when you're
soliciting value out of people yeah like
you're like you know what I mean like
I'm asking people personal finance
questions like they're not I'm not
necessarily like like taking anything
away from them them except like maybe
they're like Financial like privacy sure
um but if you're like trying to sell
something like selling a water bottle
like what Ryan Trahan did I was like
there is no chance that I can do that
it's hard yeah trying to get something
out of random what are your thoughts on
the Ryan Trey and uh Penny challenge I
thought it's great like he basically
daily vlogged right like that I mean I
thought that you couldn't really do that
anymore but you did a great job I think
I'm I'm a huge fan of any content style
where you have to like watch multiple
videos it's like an ongoing storyline
like I love it when like most videos on
YouTube I feel like they're one-off it's
not like you watch one and then you're
waiting to see the next video like
normally on TV shows it's kind of like
that there's like a cliffhanger and then
you started back up on the next episode
and then there's another Cliffhanger so
it keeps you going so like I love that
there's an overarching storyline because
I think like there is a place for that
on YouTube it's just like really hard to
achieve because just sometimes like your
videos just don't do as well and so it's
hard to like keep that if you have
that's consistent viewership right there
so I think it's great it's like TV be
yeah in a way his ability to go up and
be like howdy you want to buy some water
and just like constant nose yeah is
incredible because I would imagine he
has to approach 100 people for like
every oh yeah five maybe they'd say yes
or one in 20. yeah so yeah guys so uh
speaking of making money
um
I sold out you sold out how'd you sell
out oh geez well here we go again I'm
gonna have to tell you guys the story
here but uh you may notice something
different about the camera angle wait a
second you don't have a uh you have a
memory card in the camera I I actually
just noticed that this is the first time
let me explain you guys what happened I
was uh minding my own business on
Instagram when I got this message from
Lexar Lexar if you guys didn't know is
an SD card company and they said they
wanted to send me a SD card so I stuck
it in the camera and you know what else
I said
I said
why don't you guys sponsor me and I
don't give any of the profits to Graham
and Jack and I stick a sign right here I
think that's a terrible idea I think
that's a really really bad idea but on
the bright side guys they did send you
guys some card readers oh good cards so
I'll bust you guys for that but uh so
yeah guys the official memory sponsor of
the podcast or myself so have you guys
have you guys really not seen this no
Elliot I was kind of aware of it but I'm
still I'm still a little in shock that
it's actually happening we're gonna
change the direction of this
conversation
I can't believe that that's funny that's
funny
one thing oh my gosh Alex we'll have it
we're gonna have a talk we're gonna have
a very very serious talk about this Alex
as you know what how much do they pay
you know what this is this is a pain
we'll do this as a midweek episode to
keep you guys watching so you have to
subscribe to see our our confrontation
with Alex about what's going on here
yeah so uh now we have a Continuing
Story That's funny There You Go gosh
Alex that's funny so I thought you guys
it cost to sell out Alex well I guess
just I I can't listen man I can't reveal
my secrets but if you're interested hit
me up on Instagram okay yeah I don't
know yeah and also it would be funny if
all of a sudden like everywhere
I think it'd be funny if you had a hat
with like a dangling thing
I mean look how much retail space I mean
there's a scientific figure one up here
we got some space right here too we have
a lot of yeah we could sell out really
big guys you can't take my money making
wait a second is that the iced coffee
hour a fancy a fan oh yeah the other one
behind the hard drive oh no no no
no there's nothing a fan made us that
thing and you're covering it up with
your sponsor no no no how does that feel
I don't know listen the fans should be
happy for me okay I'm I'm making some
jack what are you doing what are you
doing
what are you doing come on oh the fans
come first someone made that man the
fans come first all right guys all right
I mean that needs to be you know what
there we go the fans come first I just
wanted to keep those there to let you
guys know that is so funny I saw that
and I was like oh nice you guys got like
you know like oh no they didn't no they
they genuinely didn't I was like oh you
guys are doing like sponsored uh a
cigarette in here yeah one thing that I
wanted to talk about with you is that
you're in a Content house aren't you yes
I'm uh in a Creator house it's called
your mom's house your mom's house
actually is it actually called your
mom's house I actually called your mom's
house don't talk about my mom like that
so you're in your mom's house yeah okay
you're still living with your mom I'm I
live in my mom's no I live in your mom's
house actually no no I live in your mom
your mom's house yeah I know I do live
in your mom's house yeah there you go
your mom's house so
um mom's house seems pretty nice though
your mom's house yeah it is we're all
getting confused yeah your mom's house
but you live in a Creator house you said
right yeah and um what's like the reason
behind that and I've also noticed like
all of these companies going and like
sponsoring these houses yeah and they're
usually like Mansions or super nice
places if you have any like Insider
information on that or or how exactly
did your mom's house come about yeah
it's not like a typical Creator house
like we don't have like Brands
sponsoring it and like we're not even
making money off of it like it's very
much just friends that are creators that
happen to live live with each other
um actually not even in the house
because we live in New York so in an
apartment
so technically that name is not even
right uh it should be your mom's
apartment but yeah no we um we're just
like a group of friends and like we live
together and we make videos together it
so I did this like month in La where I
like live with creators it wasn't a
Creator house it wasn't like a Content
house
um and and I mean it was in the sense
that like creators living together but
it was very much just like super natural
and organic and it was like the best
month ever like we made videos together
it was like very organic collaboration
um and it was fun it was just super fun
and we learned a lot off of each other
and so like we went back I went back to
college a lot of people went back to
school and I was like okay like how can
we like do this again after college it's
like such a good environment to be in
um and so that's when we started the
house like
I guess it's been a year now bro yeah
who else is in first please uh Kelly
with Casa your mom Ashley so there's
some inspiration for the name there he
previously had a member her name was
Amber Chase she's no longer part of the
house and then we have like some new
members coming so yeah it's very much
just like an apartment
for New York it's like spacious like
it's really hard to find a lot of space
in New York so for New York it's quite
spacious so
it's not like a it's not a luxury
high-rise like it's not a no it's not
like it's pretty good in the photos I've
seen there the video yeah it's a little
bit ratchet actually like but it's nice
because like we beat it up a little bit
like we got a skate ramp in there
and that's weird for New York for sure
skate ramp in the place there's a half
pipe it there wow yeah why is he the
movie Big yeah that's exactly what I was
thinking yeah yeah we're just like I
don't know just kids like
screwing around in there so how much is
rent rent you know you know uh you
reacted to my what I spend in a week I
do yeah and you uh we're spot on so for
me I think it was uh do you remember
what you said I probably said 7 500
bucks 65. no not for me uh so me
personally yeah or a month
four thousand bucks a month for me yeah
do you have like the nicest room I don't
have the master I I think I have the
nicest room low key
but they wouldn't agree uh no I think
they would agree I feel like I'm the
nicest room okay I think I got lucky but
it's not the it's not the master it's
not the master
pays a little more but so you got a good
deal do the math and yeah all right yeah
but yeah in the what I spend in a week
video I'm spending a lot of money going
out and uh you know I think I gave you a
lot of uh criticism that I think after
speaking to you now was uh unwarranted
oh yeah yeah I do I think it was
warranted you're going straight you're
going to coffee shops you're spending
like eight dollars on designer coffee 15
avocados hosts but now that I'm hearing
about it that this is like your
full-time thing and going out making
content you can't really make the
content like that being like hey guys
I'm gonna make my coffee at home and
have an avocado with us by myself and
I'm gonna invite someone over at the
house today we're gonna it's more
entertaining to watch you go somewhere
even if it's at a cost because your cost
is at that point just the the price of
doing business it's a little bit of both
like I mean honestly yeah I could
definitely cook a little bit more like
that's I don't know it's something I'm
trying to work on
um you inspire me to like try to cook
more but
no it is also like sometimes I'm like
okay I can like film it if I'm like
going out and like meeting up with a
friend I think New York is obviously
like very glamorized like people like
the idea of like going to New York and
like what is life like and if I just
stay in my apartment all day it's like I
don't get to show off the city as much
so there's like that but no I should
definitely be cooking more I'm just like
terrible at it so and when you're trying
to figure out like which day you're
gonna Vlog is it based off of if you
know something's gonna happen that day
or do you just pick a random day I'm
gonna Vlog today and then you try to
create exciting stuff in that day yeah
that's that's pretty accurate like if I
if something's gonna happen already like
I might just like add in a few more
things to like make it a little bit more
interesting that being said like
sometimes I just like commit to like I'm
gonna Vlog that day and I have nothing
planned it's always a really tough
vlogging day but I only Vlog like really
one day out of the week so would you say
you work a lot in general
um I do like I always used to work way
more because I was in college so like
balancing school and and YouTube
um nowadays I still do do work a lot but
I also like hiring people and like
working with more people like is
definitely like I don't edit my own
videos anymore like still a little bit
of retouching but
yeah so so like that saves a lot of time
like focus on more things so walk us
through a normal day what do you do
because it seems like if you don't you
don't want to watch a video you'd rather
just keep telling the thing is it's like
if you don't edit the video and you
spend one day a week vlogging yeah what
do you do what that's a great question
it's just like so different every single
day like usually I wake up I go get some
coffee get some food in me uh go to the
computer just like go through some
emails
um maybe get lunch with someone it's
like a meeting
um yeah I think about like if I if I
need to plan some videos like I'll just
like bring some video ideas
um a lot of times I'm like working on
copyright so like talking to
manufacturers or like talking to my team
and
it's just like all over the place like a
lot of like meeting up with people a lot
of uh planning videos or like thinking
about YouTube but then also like
planning
um copyright and doing operation stuff
there it's really different like every
day I couldn't tell you it's just like
all over the place and then sometimes I
travel so
that gets in the way
it's a lot it's pretty amazing because
you only had like four hours of screen
time so you're like not on your phone
that much no I'm not on my phone too uh
this is a good week so it's a good one
yeah let's go week yeah
wow yeah it's hard to be on your phone
when you're at lunch every day Jack yeah
you're going out to breakfast every
morning yeah dinner every night I've
been eating out every single day have
you really yeah I have every zoolie
every single day why I get Chipotle
every single day oh you're doing the
Alex hormones nope okay so let me
explain let me you know who Alex is no I
don't he's like this like entrepreneur
guy only is Chipotle uh kind of he did
yeah for for a period of time for a year
or so uh I I decided I don't want to
cook in the kitchen takes too long it's
exhausting I always buy a bunch of stuff
from the grocery store it always goes
bad I feel like I'm wasting food but if
I just go to Chipotle a bowl is like a
meal and a half for me yeah you know and
I make some overnight oats and that's
pretty much I'm good for the day there
you go overnight oats and like Chipotle
Bowl uh and Alex ramosi said that his
accountant came to him and was like Hey
it says here that you ordered Chipotle
like 500 and so times this year there
must be some sort of error and then Alex
said like no that's right yeah that's
right so why don't you try Chipotle
catering because that would give you
enough to make your own bowls for a
whole week that is a really good idea
that is an extremely good idea we just
need to win one of those my friends like
one of my friends had the Chipotle card
it's like a year of free Chipotle try to
um he just won it it's like won it in a
sweepstakes and he got like 50 of
Chipotle every day what was one I would
I've completely forgot there was a was
it like a Souplantation thing or was
that all you could eat pasta from Olive
Garden that was it that's a thing yep
and they gave away 500 of these but you
had to apply for it and then there's a
lottery system where you have to sign in
at a certain time to buy it it was like
a hundred dollars for it was all you
could eat at Olive Garden for like a
year or something like really yeah I
thought I was gonna buy it for a video
and that morning like I had applied I
had secured a spot to go and like buy it
yeah but you had to be really quick and
I overslept
it's like uh that's like a you know that
old like American Airlines like
reflect it was what was it 250 grand for
free flights for oh yeah yeah it's like
best like that yeah
yeah well what about you guys like what
is your day-to-day like every typical
day oh Jack you want to go first your
busy schedule yeah so usually what I do
is I wake up right and then I go to the
gym that's generally speaking like the
first thing I do uh I come back home eat
a little bit of food overnight oats
maybe and uh take a shower and then get
ready start working pretty much so that
would work work yeah sometimes I have
some stuff to do surprisingly and I'll
usually take care of some work uh
probably done by like
dumbbell done by 11 A.M probably done
with all my work no uh I keep working
usually take some breaks I play a lot of
ping pong oh really I just go back to
work I usually don't go out it's pretty
much just like I'm in my room on my
computer basically all day yeah uh
that's pretty much it a lot of the times
I come over here to film sponsors or
we'll be filming podcasts and uh that's
pretty much I I don't go out yeah I live
in like a a Suburban type uh you live in
a Content house jack I kind of do yeah I
mean all five rooms are filled up with
kids that are between the age of 20 hits
with men
like adults right like it feels weird
saying that because I still feel like
I'm a kid but it's between the age of 21
and 23. so we're and we're yeah like a
couple of us like making YouTube I'm 23
23 okay yeah so kind of a Content house
yeah but we mess around you know we have
fun yeah it'd be funny if you call it
your dad's house
my place is your dad's house yeah the
guys will love that one yeah yeah that's
good all right yeah yeah that's pretty
much the average day
oh man every day is every day is
different
um it depends if it's a posting day or a
non-posting day but usually like Monday
Wednesday Fridays I'll wake up try to
plan out a video Alex comes between 12
and 1. we review the video that's
posting that day we'll spend two hours
thinking title thumbnail answer comments
for an hour afterwards and then after
that usually we'll either be filming a
podcast I'll go to the gym I'll react to
a video for the second Channel or I'll
film what I planned out earlier and then
Tuesdays and Thursdays are usually
planning days where I'll spend all day
just trying to script out videos to then
post the next day or that that following
day because I was gonna say you you pump
out a lot of videos like I was gonna say
you have to just be filming a lot every
day every day every day every day one
video a day because you have what like
three channels uh three channels posting
seven days a week so there's a video
posting every day and that and that's
actually down at the peak I think it was
12 videos a week wow and I did that for
a few months
uh actually it was nine videos a week
for I think almost a year
a year Giver take nine videos a week
that's crazy went up to 12 for a month
and then now I'm back down to seven and
you think seven is where you're gonna
stay uh for as long as I can yeah yeah
actually seven years old close to
midweek episode seven is still a lot
yeah do you ever feel like normal really
yeah well you're coming from 12. so yeah
exactly so it's just whatever the
threshold is but like three of those
videos don't count because I think those
are the reaction videos so that's just
me like reacting to a video pretty easy
it's an hour title thumbnail yeah not
the end of the world uh the podcast is
simple because it's just one day a week
yeah and that's usually something like
this it feels kind of like hanging out
it's the three main Channel videos a
week gotcha that's a lot yeah it's still
a lot
every video is its own video like
there's a lot It's gotta be its own
topic yeah and especially in times like
this there's not a lot to yeah talk
about that it's that different so
there's got to be topics that repeat
because sometimes people don't watch
they'll they'll be a topic on a video
and people won't watch that one but
they'll watch the next one sometimes
it's just it's you know busy yeah so
there's got to be some topics that
repeat every now is that your biggest
challenge like coming out with new video
ideas yeah yeah if I had uh a list of
topics where all I knew is just like all
right Graham you got to plan out this
video this day uh
I could I could do that so easily if
they had the video just yeah topic video
topic title thumbnail done and then all
I had to do was plan it out and film it
would be so easy but part of it is like
trying to see what I watch so much
YouTube videos to try to figure out like
what people want to see and they'll
create videos around that right very
little about like what I care about at
this point it's just whatever the
viewers want to see and it's dictated by
how many views uh each video gets what
is that different from in the beginning
in the beginning were you just like
making things that you wanted to make
yeah and then now is it like okay you
feel a little bit more responsibility of
like no I have to now create for like my
viewers not totally yeah in the
beginning it was really fun because
these were videos that I wanted to make
that didn't exist right and the finance
base on YouTube was nothing yeah and so
when I saw it I was like oh wow
um there's no videos on being a real
estate agent these are the videos that I
wish were up there for me yeah and so
I'd make all these videos and financial
Independence very quickly became a thing
in like 2017 on YouTube yeah no one was
making these videos except beat the bush
and maybe like two other people but they
were they weren't doing well with title
thumbnails so I thought wow uh we could
make this so much bigger with a good
title and a good thumbnail how sacking
was it was one of the first videos for
me that did well that didn't exist on
YouTube with that sort of title
thumbnail that would attract an audience
right
um but as the space grew it became way
more competitive because now everybody's
doing the same videos the same day
because there's nothing so when you have
a hundred creators all searching the
internet for the same topics and there's
one little nibble of something they're
gonna hop on it fast yeah and so if I
don't cover a topic within 24 hours
everyone else has already covered it
there's no need for my take on that so
now you're you feel like you're more
like almost like a news Outlet like you
got to be fast with it yeah because I'm
never gonna be the fastest because you
have other people who will literally
live stream the event right right and
they provide such great context on that
so I know I can't compete with that sure
there are other people who will just
freestyle a video within an hour
afterwards yeah you can't do that so
mine is always I'll come to it with the
with as much perspective as possible
yeah in a way that's you know edited and
informative and entertaining right but
it's got to be within 24 hours that's
interesting yeah that's so interesting I
also feel that we're like in the
beginning it was like a huge gap and
you're like okay I can fill this Gap
there's a huge gap in the market and now
it's like super interesting where it's
not so much of that it's more just like
how do I keep growing like what I've
built yeah it's hard to see where the
next Gap is uh because for a while I
think Jake Tran really got on that
bandwagon or do you watch his channel
yeah yeah he got in that bandwagon of
just a really cool like documentary
style videos yeah but now I'm seeing
everybody making documentary Styles like
um moon is another Channel I've been
watching a lot of that makes similar
videos just different topics but it's
like these documentary style videos are
popping off same with like Patrick CC
sunnyv2 like the the rise and fall of
like like narrated very dramatic they do
so well but so many channels now are
popping up like that it's hard to figure
out like where's the need now in the
marketplace and like what's next yeah
it's like that intersection of like what
where's the Gap and like what are you
good at like for you is probably very
clear so I'm trying to find it too I
think there's a lot of like soul
searching on YouTube yeah like who am I
like who Am I who do I want to be not to
get so deep or whatever but I think I
think I don't know if you feel the same
way but just on YouTube it's just a lot
of like and I feel like are you like
Jack you're trying to like figure out
you're trying on YouTube as well or I
suppose so I mean basically all my focus
on is on the iced coffee hour and on my
off time like I'm just kind of doing
whatever I guess I have fun with yeah
I'm on my own personal channel uh that's
pretty much I guess I kind of in in a
sense trying to find what I like because
every single video I've posted has been
a completely different format like a
reaction versus like a challenge versus
like a strangerous question yeah I mean
there's so many like different type of
types of videos on YouTube and I feel
like a lot of people starting off are
just like okay what's gonna do well like
how can I make something that does well
um but I think it's actually the
opposite like what am I good at like
yeah who am I as a person like what can
I bring to the platform it's there's I
don't know it's a different game I don't
know it's a different thing how often do
you have those feelings or go through
those moments oh like all the time like
I always have to do a ton of soul
searching like who am I like who do I
want to be like what I stand for or what
am I good at in the beginning it was so
clear like okay College videos like I
didn't like the ones that were being
made but they're doing well so like okay
I can make ones that I like and they'll
hopefully do well
um but yeah now I'm like I really feel
like I'm approaching a little bit of a
pivot actually which is also kind of
scary yeah I'm just like trying to think
of like
what's prompted that
um just like being
just not complacent but just doing
making similar videos and like not
really innovating and growing so I think
it's like a constant cycle of like okay
you were really happy with the videos
you're making and then you're not so
happy with them and then you change
something up and like try to make them
better and you become happy with them do
you feel like you've stagnated in a way
like you've kind of peaked and plateaued
in terms of like what you are currently
capable of I think like I haven't been
as like creative and I think part of it
is actually also like having an editor
now like not being as like not being
able to like do as much creatively
because like I there's only so much you
can communicate like creatively and it
is a challenge
um and then I think YouTube also is a
lot about like consistency over like
trying to like change it up all the time
but a lot of times for myself like it
comes from like making videos this comes
from a place of like wanting to share
something like creatively so it's a
balance because like you don't want to
switch it up too hard because then that
kind of like is not good for your
channel but at the same time I think
it's like important to like think about
how you want to innovate and like bring
something new I think you guys need a
soundboard do you guys have a soundboard
[Music]
yeah we'll play one of those but like
right here and then you guys could be
like sound effects yeah like oh like how
much you make this yeah exactly a low
number but we're already pressing it
yeah just for comedian effect no I think
you guys do great okay this side is
crazy this is something else huh what is
something you think you can work on I
mean I can work on I can work on a lot
of things this could be business related
personal yeah anything I think a lot of
times I just need to remind myself to
like
be patient I think I'm I'm 23 too like
I'm just very young and I think like
YouTube is going well and there's a lot
of great opportunities there and like
I'm excited about it but I also like
like you said Graham I want to like
maximize my life experience still
um I just like I don't know there's a
lot of pressure because there's a lot of
like opportunities and you want to make
sure you're like making the most of it
but at the same time I'm just
I'm really young like I feel like I I am
really young and still have a lot of um
going to do so I always feel like I need
I need to be in a position where I'm
learning the most and early on on
YouTube that was YouTube just like how
do I learn how to like grow on YouTube
all that stuff and I think like I'm
learning different things nowadays but
yeah I think like I really have to think
critically about like what is gonna make
me kind of like a more well-rounded
person that's really interesting because
I'm the same age as you but I see it in
a different way I feel like like I'm
going slow I feel like I need to like
speed things up I feel like I'm too too
old you know what I mean like I don't
like excuse my like naivety even though
I am only 23. you know what I mean yeah
you feel like a sense of urgency you're
running out of time not that I'm running
out of time but like a sense of urgency
in so far as that I'm like racing you
know what I mean that I gotta keep going
like hit some gold hit something you
know what I mean yeah I mean I've been
there too like just trying to like reach
the next Milestone and reach the next
Milestone and I'm interested here Graham
your perspective on this too but
I used to just move the goal post like
yeah I just keep moving it but after a
while it's like
just not the same as
I don't know I would tell you to keep
going and for Jack Jack I I'd say oh
double your output
there's so much more I feel like there's
so much more I I'd say uh a lot more
guest Outreach I think a lot more
um picking videos for the second Channel
I would say for the filming I don't know
your filming schedule right now but I
pick one day a week like you know
Saturday or something like that where
you just film for six to eight hours
um I'm fine if you Outsource the editing
on those videos
the the you going in the public like
there's no sense of you editing those
videos yeah I agree yeah just It's just
tough to find an editor
well I guarantee that it's not tough
there are probably hundreds of people
right now who would love to be your
editor the only thing that I'll say as a
Counterpoint to that is the fact that
and I mean this in no offense I mean
it's the most respectful way every
single every single time you've seen
that I I really mean it in a respectful
way because I think that there's a lot
about you that is extremely admirable
but when I look at you and I see that
you're continuing to push and you're
pushing and you're pushing and you're
gonna hold out for as long as you can
and you've been saying the same thing
for years but it seems like like you
haven't like traveled you haven't like
gone and do things that I would at least
find enjoyable like maybe you find
enjoyment in sitting down and working
but that's just not how I I find a lot
of enjoyment I I like trying out things
and being creative and filming new
videos and doing trying out new things
but when I see you I'm like God I do not
want to to like in 10 years I don't want
to be like that but the thing is it's
like now is the opportunity when you
have that golden egg and you have that
golden opportunity you shouldn't waste
it when you think of how many people
would would love to be in that position
if you don't give it 110 you don't make
the most of it I feel like it's being
wasted I agree that it can easily be
wasted but I I think as it currently
stands I'm actually doing a very good
job I think you're wasting it I don't I
think you're doing a good job
but I don't think it means taking it
easier being complacent or not pushing
yourself even further because I've seen
more people not give it 110 and and lose
it than have pushed and maybe gotten an
extra few years
I just think it's such a volatile career
but you can say you keep pushing for an
extra few years and then a few years
pass and you're like keep pushing but
there's just like a truck there's going
to be a point of diminishing returns at
a certain point it either your income
scales
at direct proportion to that or your
other investments just become more to to
offset everything I think there'll be a
point of diminishing returns where all
of a sudden I think life experience
trumps the opportunity of of continuing
as is what do you think about this I
think it's really important to like know
what your priorities are like what is
important to you what are you willing to
sacrifice I think people are different
like some people like a lot of it is
like
how you grew up or like what were your
childhood influences or traumas or
whatever I think it matters a lot like
you do have to like listen to yourself a
little bit I like for me I needed that
push a lot like people just telling me
like you're not working hard enough and
they got me to like work harder and it
got me to place where I was happy but I
do think like
it just depends on like what's important
to you like just gotta ask yourself that
because different things are important
to different people so I agree with that
and I think I have a fairly good idea of
what's important to me but Graham likes
to continue to play over my shoulder no
this is what's important to you Jack
this is what's important it helps to
have someone pushing I agree I I am
pushing but I think that it's better
when it comes from a more encouraging
places
for the fact that I'm pushing means I
believe that you have the potential I
wouldn't push someone who I don't think
has the potential to do it okay wasting
my time what's your personality type do
you know uh it's an introvert of some
sense
how do you know that because we took a
test on the day podcast I think it's
super funny like seeing the interaction
because so I'm like an ENFJ and I just
took like I didn't take the test
recently but I like looked it up
recently and it was funny like one of
the things that it said it was like oh
likes to give advice to people that that
um that he cares about or he or she
cares about
um but often too forceful in a way where
it's not received the right way and so I
was just curious but I've had this where
like
I've also been someone that like likes
to push people to like work really hard
and like go for it and it's also like
kind of backfired on me a little bit in
some like my personal relationships
because
I figure that everyone like wants the
same level success or like has the same
drive or same priorities that I do but
then I come to find out that you know
some people are just like interested in
different things or like have different
priorities and I just think it's
important to like listen to yourself and
like really listen to how you feel that
being said like I sometimes you need
that push so I do think like that
question of like what do you do every
day you know it's like such a hard
question to answer it's a very difficult
question it is like
so different every day I'm like you're
right like I do feel sometimes like I'm
really busy
and then if I look back I'm like
like what exactly am I doing like you
know like I just like write it down and
we'll sort of check my calendar it just
gets blurred yeah there is a lot during
the day though even for myself that you
realize you waste doing stuff that
doesn't really matter yeah I'll spend a
lot of time sometimes I'll be in the
middle of planning but my mind is just
down surround I'll check my email for
five minutes yeah and then that leads to
checking CNBC for five minutes which
leads to checking Reddit for five
minutes and then I get back to planning
but it takes me 20 minutes to get back
into the zone so there's like 40 minutes
it's gone
um that didn't need to be gone yeah I
used to think that like if I wasn't
working from the moment that I woke up
to the moment that I fall asleep then I
wasn't working hard at all but I really
think that like quality work matters way
more than the hours you put in like
there's a lot that you can do I agree
100 I think that matters a lot yeah it's
tough for me because I just I've all
I've always had this mentality that your
20s could be like completely sacrificed
to set yourself up for the rest of your
life and I think if if people just gave
themselves from 18 to 30 just to put
their head down and work and just bust
their ass like all the time maybe see
you know the occasional weekend trip or
whatever but like the focus should be
work for 12 years I I I'm curious to see
how many people would be
um further ahead yeah if if they really
gave it a hundred percent
um and that's and not to discredit
people who you know maybe in a job that
they don't like yeah a bajillion other
things can come up but to really be like
very dedicated right of like I'm gonna
spend these next 12 years and I'm gonna
work on myself every day yeah I think
it's great like I also think it's
idealistic like a lot of people I think
just don't don't care for it like that's
fair I'm a little bit more like work
slash experience on that Spectrum like I
care about like experiencing like stuff
like travel it it seems like Worth to me
just like go travel and like experience
life and
just like how you said like oh 20 it's
time time to like work and like grind
and like set yourself up for life I
could also be like oh 20s it's a time
when like you're young and like you can
travel and then you can tolerate like
that's true you know now going to like
different places like five different
places in a week you can't do that when
you're you know
a lot older it's just like harder so I
don't know it's a balance I just think
it depends on what's important too you
as a person yeah I guess I've never had
the urgency to to go and do those things
because I feel like I could do them
anytime if I really place the importance
on that I could do it right and that's
that's a conscious decision for you
that's like okay I could do that but I
don't want to because I would rather do
this so that's like your values and I
think like that's that's what it is I
think if you are as long as you're
aligned like with your action and what
you value then you're living a good life
because like what more could you do is
like if you if you were living out the
life that's in line with your values
yeah I think that's that's really the
goal do you guys live like living out
here in Vegas love it really yeah what
do you like about it I like that there's
no traffic I went across town the other
day at uh was it 6 p.m was the same as
driving in the morning on a Sunday uh or
you know Saturday no traffic yeah and it
was a tax is fantastic the food I had 25
all you can eat sushi the other day food
is good 25 for the quality sushi with a
good fish to rice ratio very good
um everything about it just the the
people here are very friendly uh the
neighbors now we know the neighbors we
we wave to the neighbors there you go
walk down and a neighbor will come up
and say hi nice uh Alex is working with
uh some neighbors now which is cool Ox
picked up
it's just really friendly really nice
can you take the heat uh he's not bad
because I'm inside all day ah it doesn't
really matter yeah at night it's really
nice because you because you go out it's
kind of like a little warm but it's like
a comfortable woman yeah do you think
you'll stay here for a while I do for
many years decades most likely decades
for the rest of your life I mean too
early to tell but where did you grow up
in Los Angeles okay so that's why you
think the traffic is good because it's
terrible yeah interesting
have you lived anywhere else
uh nope are you willing to I'd be poison
you'll be open to it yeah have you lived
anywhere else uh I grew up in Ventura
which is an hour north of L.A and then
that's where you like grew up in yeah I
grew up in Ventura and then I moved to
UCSB and then from there I moved in with
him gotcha Santa Monica and then here
interesting yeah yeah I would say go go
live somewhere for a year I want to live
in New York yeah come to New York New
York for one year I told myself that I
think that everyone should try New York
for a year that's what a lot of people
say yeah I really feel like you learn a
lot about yourself in New York it's a
really tough City and it's very
uncomfortable but that's what that's
just a charm actually yeah what is it
about New York though it's uncomfortable
it's just like so it's everything's
expensive it's very like you don't get a
lot of space it's dirty it smells it's
like the the weather is like really
harsh and I kind of like that because it
keeps me like on my toes and it kind of
like keeps me I don't know it's like a
cold shower it's equivalent of like a
cold shower like
I don't know it's hard to explain that
makes sense you learn a lot about
yourself when you're like under those
conditions I feel like all the people
that I know that have spoken about
living in New York speak very fondly of
it yeah I don't think I'm gonna live
there you know past my after I turn 30
but I'd probably spend my 20s in New
York just because it's I don't know
there's you know there's plenty of
things wrong with it tax is one of them
but um it's just
like I said I'm someone who like
maximizes like cares a lot about
experiences
and I go through a lot there like in a
lot of different ways in a lot of
different areas of my life personal work
everything so I don't know I've learned
a lot about myself just because there's
a lot of Trials there what about those
experiences like what stands out to you
um like this past year a lot of like
personal experiences like dealing with
friends like a lot of my personal
relationships
um are that is also like living in a
Creator house like obviously very
complicated
but I've learned so much about like
navigating some things like even stuff
like me not being a confrontational
person but then then by nature of like
trying to do business and then also live
with friends like having to work on that
skill that's an example of like
something in my personal life
um just areas of growth that like you
would find
you would not find unless you were fake
like put in those specific situations I
think like every every few months like I
go through like some stuff in New York
and I learn a lot about like myself and
I think I come out usually like a better
person just having grown and it's not
always just like career stuff a lot of
personal stuff and
um I care I care a lot about like the
personal career work life balance so
it's important to me to like focus on
everything right yeah so we're gonna be
taking questions from our audience from
the fans on patreon okay here's some
questions for you from Ben what is your
process from making videos to uploading
videos I feel like we answered that
pretty well yeah uh plan out a day bring
my camera around is there anything in
that day that you know hits for the
audience you're like they love when I go
to this one coffee shop not necessarily
I do try to fit in a talking segment
into every video which doesn't always
work out because people click off of
like talking segments usually in the
Vlog like you see the retention go like
this when you start are talking but I do
think like it's really important to
build that audience relationship by
talking to them directly like a lot of
times it's more like the viewers just
like oh sorry like watching in on you
versus like you're actually there and
they're talking directly to you I think
that's a different type of Creator where
do you Source do you stock b-roll stock
b-roll no
you don't stock stock b-roll yeah no you
don't use any stock b-roll no why would
I use stock Bureau what if there's a
something you're trying to explain and
there's a really nice you know stock
footage I don't know I just never have
used b-roll like that I mean I use my
own b-roll
I don't use stock b-roll it's not my
style that's interesting I feel like all
we use is stock b-roll pretty much
pretty much that's like every all of the
huh
I don't know I just never have like I'm
showing my life it's weird if I kind of
show someone else's footage Shelby
church I think does the same she films
such good b-roll I think she's got a
backlog she has to have a catalog of
just like her walking in a 100 different
spots like her in a grocery store and
like different buildings and stuff and
then she could pull back from this right
I also don't do voiceovers like oh yeah
so that's a little different why not
don't you think that would be a good
idea I want to experiment more with
voiceovers just because it's a little
bit more versatile I just like for the
longest time I've been doing this
and just talking so that's what I'm used
to but I'm actually really interested in
like experimenting more what about
walking around with that thing do you
get embarrassed like filming out in
public not anymore like in the beginning
yeah but I got over real quick just a
lot of just like loud and proud you know
just like really just you gotta for me
it's like if I don't do it no one's
gonna do for me if I don't do it right
then if I don't get the high enough this
is not a good shot you know like this is
the right shot yeah straight on yeah
like what about looks at you in public
or do people ever try to interfere
because I just don't care if they like
hey yeah um I read four hour work week
my freshman year of college and in there
there's a bunch of like uncomfortable
exercises that you're supposed to do and
one of them was like lying on the ground
in the public area for like five minutes
so in the middle of uh lunch like in my
College dining hall interior okay dining
hall I would just lie down in the middle
like you know you you're scared of
judgments tell your friends you were
doing it no I just do it like and people
are just like what are you doing
um or just random stuff like push-ups in
the middle of nowhere and like weirdest
looks obviously very judgmental looks
and like a lot of judgment from my my
friends and like people that I was like
meeting because it's a freshman year of
college
um but it really trained me like super
well to just like not care like I need
what I need to get done I get done like
I don't care if it's like this and if I
have to yell or whatever it's just like
practice it's cool yeah what other like
challenges did you do from the four hour
work week that was the one that was the
most memorable I don't really remember I
think it was one it was maintain icon oh
I did that the other person looks away I
did that where you just maintain eye
contact and then it gets very
uncomfortable really fast with someone
you're not talking to yeah I was just
saying like you're sitting over here
there's someone else sitting over there
no even even during a conversation like
you want to look like you could do it
right now like you really did yeah we
both read the books so we're just gonna
go forever really like I can probably
just go forever unless I just like keep
talking and get you to look away but no
he's just gazing to each other you
really want to look away I know like
right now
now my eyes are just getting watery so I
was like also not blinking so that
wasn't helping yeah it's okay to Blink
yeah it's okay to Blink it's actually
weirder if you don't like that could be
an added layer yeah try that and then
report back on the next episode yeah
just with a stranger yeah it could be
with this yeah
you're talking to like it didn't you
ordered Chipotle but stare at them until
they look away yeah I mean that's not
hard because I think if I'm speaking to
someone I actually maintain I actually
maintain eye contact
I do it pretty well yeah and I'm not
really scared you should do it with
people that are just like walking by
yourself would be harder yeah if I was
just sitting down you know biting my
burrito right just staring intently it
depends how you're eating the burrito
how else would you eat it would you eat
it sideways like this
I got it Graham it's okay but yeah I
don't know I think that's definitely
something it's just got a lollipop
popsicle yeah the the props might not
really help but no it's great I actually
you know you were just talking about
being uncomfortable in public this will
help
like and not uncomfortable not
uncomfortable in public uncomfortable
asking people questions in public
settings yeah it'll actually help a lot
like um the eye contact thing is big I
gotta practice that you can lie down a
lot actually okay I'll report back yeah
I'll report back
all right well cool well thank you I
really appreciate it thanks for coming
to Vegas thanks for coming on thanks for
having me yeah you're welcome uh did you
get your free stock in the description
I'm about to right now by going down in
the description and
I can't have you followed me so with
that said you guys thank you so much for
tuning in to this episode of the iced
coffee Hour podcast thank you Elliot for
coming over here
with that said you guys until next time